cat those those chicken sandwich you
brought in
there's no way Popeyes or chick-fil-a
better there's no why do I need to try
them I mean hopefully you don't cuz some
guy died recently waiting in line for a
Popeye sandwich there was a dispute at
Maryland between two men one man said
that the other cut in line right before
him and they got into a verbal argument
which then led to one guy stabbing the
other a 28-year old man they don't
specify whether he was the one who cut
in line or the guy who was waiting in
line originally but he was rushed to the
hospital after getting stabbed a couple
of times and he actually passed away
damn a chicken sandwich damn does anyone
ever died over a McRib yeah it sounds
like you had two [ __ ] they had a
that a surplus and Mister mcribs that's
why dogs like there's a [ __ ] scarcity
of pop I didn't even gotten to find at
Costco Popeyes didn't matter although he
might have been hungry when you're
hungry but here's the problem like
people like kids they have gotten
murdered or they got robbed and stabbed
for Jordans because there's such a
limited amount of them scare people yeah
so people have like this urge like oh
I'm gonna miss out and then they kill
[ __ ] yeah beanie babies
Elmo terregino freaking out cheers I'm
when Jared Diamond is the great
he wrote Guns Germs and Steel and he
studies indigenous cultures and he was
up in a Papa New Guinea where these
tribes were really isolated and he said
they get along man it's all good as long
as they have access to resources as soon
as there is a lack of water and one
group has a better control of that water
the group over here is necessary quickly
starts coming up with reasons they start
making up stories and coming up with
reasons why that group over there needs
to die and they'll start speaking
genocide and and there are instances
world this tribe will come over their
sand the highlands they've been isolated
for 40,000 years and they'll wipe them
all out I mean like now they're in the
way we need water dude if I know
Thursday
it's what this guy's saying chicken
can't give it you can't listen chicken
Sam stab you over chick example these
what where's our from Hattie's no Howlin
race Howlin ready Hattie's where's that
Chinatown downtown LA is it is it a
Asian nope
a white guy opened it up hell yeah white
right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue good what's gonna happen what are
you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[Laughter]